Is Bane a dark reflection of who
Bruce could have become if he'd
followed a different path? Does Alfred
really see Bruce in Florence? We're
here to shed some light on the finer
points of "The Dark Knight Rises."
Picking up eight years after "The Dark Knight,"
Christopher Nolan's third installment introduces
us to a mostly peaceful Gotham City, a tormented
Commissioner Gordon, and a reclusive Bruce Wayne,
who stopped being Batman after framing
himself for Harvey Dent's murder. But
after cat burglar Selina Kyle steals Bruce's
mother's pearls and the mercenary Bane arrives
and recruits the young men of Gotham
to his cause to tear down the city,
Bruce dons the cape and cowl once
more. Only this time, he fails.
After Bane breaks his back, Bruce is taken
to a Middle Eastern prison to watch from
afar as the former League of Shadows
member dismantles Gotham from within.
Separating the city from the mainland,
Bane turns Gotham into a no man's land
ruled "by the people." Of course, that's
all a mirage, as Bane's men are parading
a nuclear bomb throughout the city with
a mysterious triggerman at the ready.
With Batman away, Detective John Blake —
a man who had previously deduced Batman's
secret identity — steps up to help defend Gotham
in the Dark Knight's absence, but one cop and an
underground resistance aren't enough. As Bruce
heals, he eventually succeeds in escaping from the
prison and returning to Gotham for a rematch with
his latest nemesis, even if it means his death.
By the time Bruce returns to Gotham,
the nuclear weapon has deteriorated to
the point where it's set to detonate any
day. Alongside his allies, Gordon, Blake,
and Selina Kyle — who has since repented of her
own role in all of this — Batman takes to the
streets with an army of Gotham police officers
to take back the city from Bane and his men. The
Gotham police force overpowers Bane's men, while
Batman disarms Bane and demands the trigger.
"Where is it!? Where is the
trigger!? Where is it!?"
Only Bane doesn't have it. As it turns out,
Bruce's one-time lover and Wayne Enterprises
ally Miranda Tate is the real mastermind
behind Bane's plot. Unbeknownst to Batman,
Tate's real name is Talia al Ghul, making
her the daughter of Bruce's former mentor
Ra's al Ghul. After Talia betrays Bruce,
Selina rescues the Caped Crusader and helps
him track down the nuclear weapon. Batman
takes it upon himself to fly the warhead
out into the Atlantic Ocean and allow it to
detonate far away from the people of Gotham.
As the city honors Batman, Lucius Fox, Alfred
Pennyworth, Jim Gordon, and John Blake honor
Bruce's sacrifice. But as it turns out, Bruce
didn't die after all. After handing the keys
to the Batcave over to Blake, Bruce and Selina
relocate to Italy, where Alfred watches from afar.
The last-minute reveal that Miranda Tate is
actually the daughter of Bruce's original
mentor-turned-nemesis threw many
for a loop. Throughout the film,
a story is told about a child born in a Middle
Eastern prison, the child of Ra's al Ghul, who
climbs up and out of the pit. For a long time, the
movie leads one to believe that Bane is the child.
Longtime DC Comics fans likely saw this twist
coming: the most prominent child of Ra's al Ghul
in the Batman comics is Talia, who also happens
to be Bruce's on-again/off-again lover. In fact,
aside from having led the League
of Assassins — an alternate name
for the League of Shadows — Talia is also
the mother of Batman's son Damian Wayne,
the current Robin. Of course, in "The
Dark Knight Rises," Bruce and Talia
only spend one night together, and their
passion doesn't result in a pregnancy.
Though Talia isn't mentioned directly in "Batman
Begins," the first of Nolan's trilogy alludes to
Ra's al Ghul having a family of his own. No
wonder that Talia would eventually return
to enact revenge on the Caped Crusader, who
she holds responsible for her father's death.
From the moment Bruce is first robbed by Selina,
he becomes immediately infatuated with the elusive
cat burglar. In a way, Selina is the one who
inspires Bruce to become Batman once again,
and she's by his side when he first confronts
Bane. Sure, she betrays him in the process,
but all sins are forgiven once she sides
with Batman post-revolution. No wonder
these two end up together in the end,
each bringing out the best in the other.
"I like your girlfriend, Mr. Wayne."
"He should be so lucky."
Though Bruce spends much of "The
Dark Knight" trilogy pining after
his childhood friend Rachel Dawes, the
revelation that she'd moved on before
her death opens the door for a budding
romance with Catwoman. More in line
with the relationship between the two in the
original DC Comics, "The Dark Knight Rises"
makes Catwoman a bit more three-dimensional
and complicated than previous incarnations.
While it may seem strange that Bruce
and Selina end up together, it's worth
noting that they both bring much-needed
excitement to each other's lives and,
while they come from vastly different backgrounds,
they quickly learn to better understand the other.
No wonder Matt Reeves played on this again in
Batman's next solo outing, 2022's "The Batman."
Christian Bale's Batman certainly has
an exciting rogues gallery. Scarecrow
is a constant thorn in Gotham's side, Ra's al
Ghul nearly destroyed the Wayne family legacy,
and Two-Face sent the Caped Crusader underground.
Of course, few would disagree that the Joker
was the most impressive — and most deranged —
criminal that the Dark Knight ever encountered.
"You have nothing to threaten me with.
Nothing to do with all your strength."
However, Bane breaks our hero like no
other. Not only does he crush Bruce's body,
but also his soul. He would have broken Batman's
spirit too had our hero not risen above his pain.
In many ways, Tom Hardy's Bane is a dark mirror
of what Bale's Batman could have easily become.
Likewise trained by Ra's al Ghul as a member of
the League of Shadows, Bane's desire is to see
Gotham burned to the ground so that it can be
restored, completely motivated by Talia's drive
for vengeance. In "Batman Begins," Bruce felt a
similar pull and nearly killed the man who killed
his own parents. He actually might have pulled
the trigger if someone else hadn't done it first.
Instead, Bruce ends up taking the path of the
hero, hoping to inspire others to be the same.
Of course, Bane inspires a group of loyal
followers too. He even incites many of Gotham's
citizens to turn on one another, exposing
the city's darkest secrets and challenging
the status quo. If it seems like Batman and
Bane work from the same playbook, it's because
they do. They each use what Ra's al Ghul taught
them, which makes Bane all the more dangerous.
"You're evil."
"I'm necessary evil."
One of the biggest debates among
fans is whether or not Alfred's
encounter-from-afar with Bruce and Selina
at the very end of the film is real or,
in reference to director Christopher Nolan's
previous hit "Inception," only a vision of
what might have been. The case for it being
nothing more than a daydream is a compelling
one at first glance. There's no way that Batman
could have survived that nuclear explosion,
right? When would he have jumped out of
the Bat? Did Alfred just imagine it all?
Of course, there are actual answers
to these questions. For starters,
the movie explains that Bruce fixed the
Bat's autopilot off-screen — which would
have allowed him to bail long before the
explosion. There's also the fact that his
mother's pearls are missing from Wayne Manor
— pearls which Selina had grown accustomed
to. We also know that Bruce knows about
Alfred's yearly pilgrimage to Florence. So,
it seems that Bruce wants his surrogate father to
know that he is okay, all without saying a word.
Lending his thoughts, Christian Bale believes that
Bruce's happy ending was genuine. He
explained to Entertainment Weekly:
"I find it very interesting and with most films,
I tend to say 'It's what the audience thinks it
is.' My personal opinion? No, it was not a dream.
That was for real and he was just delighted that
finally he had freed himself from the privilege,
but ultimately the burden of being Bruce Wayne."
Speaking of Alfred, it seems odd
to many that Bruce's surrogate
father would leave just when he needs him most.
"Goodbye, Alfred."
Sure, Bruce tells him to, but we never imagine
he'll actually abandon Batman. Though all is
forgiven by the end of the movie, it's still
strange that Alfred isn't involved in Batman's
last stand. But when you consider how much
Alfred has had to tolerate over the years,
and how much he cares about Bruce,
it may just make sense after all.
The question of what Bruce has to give to
be Batman hangs over the entire trilogy,
but "Rises" finally addresses how
much Alfred is willing to give to
help with Bruce's quest. Christian
Bale reflected to Empire in 2020:
"Alfred asks: 'How long is this gonna go on
for? It's not gonna be forever, is it?' That
to me has always been fascinating about Bruce
Wayne. And it's no secret — in 'The Dark Knight
Rises' we come back to the original ideas of
what's happening in here, it circles back."
What Bale means is that Alfred has always
wanted what was best for Bruce — he just
didn't believe that Batman is it. He always
supported Bruce's efforts to defend Gotham,
but never at the expense of Bruce himself.
Turns out that going up against Bane is too
much for Alfred to handle, though
he regrets leaving by the end.
At the very end of the movie, it's revealed that
John Blake's legal first name is actually Robin,
a clever surprise and nice nod to Batman's
longtime comic book partner. Of course,
there have been a plethora of Robins
over the years, and in many ways,
it seems as if Blake is a sort of amalgamation of
a few of them. An agile orphan like Dick Grayson,
an angry street kid like Jason Todd, and
a skilled detective who deduces Batman's
secret identity like Tim Drake, Blake fills
the role of Batman's sidekick to a "T."
When the movie ends, Blake joins the longstanding
Robin tradition of graduating from the Dark
Knight's sidekick to becoming the Dark Knight
himself. All three of the aforementioned Robins
have become Batman at some point in the
comics, and others, such as Damian Wayne,
may do the same in the future. As "Rises"
ends, Blake locates the Batcave and is
ushered into Bruce's old life, set to take his
mentor's place as the hero Gotham deserves.
While we won't ever get to ever see
Blake's version of Batman hit the streets,
director Christopher Nolan leaves his "Dark
Knight" saga open-ended on purpose to keep
the legend of Batman alive. While it's unclear
if Blake will become the next Batman himself
or forge his own superhero identity,
Gotham is no doubt safer in his hands.
The initial trailer for "The Dark Knight
Rises" splices a philosophical quip from
Ra's al Ghul with clips from the
first two installments of the
trilogy — which ultimately sums up the
underlying message of the entire thing.
"If you make yourself more than just a
man, if you devote yourself to an ideal,
you become something else
entirely ... a legend, Mr. Wayne."
In "Batman Begins," Bruce constructs the
legend of Batman. He trains his body and
his mind to become the crime fighter that
Gotham needs — even if he's not the hero they
deserve — and saves his city by thwarting Ra's
al Ghul's plan and killing him in the process.
Batman becomes a living myth who
inspires Gothamites everywhere,
and by "The Dark Knight," Batman
has fully established himself,
even inspiring hockey-pad-wearing copycats
and theatrical criminals — like the
Joker — to come out of the woodwork
and make their own mark on Gotham.
"This town deserves a better class of
criminal, and I'm gonna give it to them."
By the time "Rises" ends, Gotham
finally recognizes what the Dark
Knight has done for them, and honors him in
the form of a statue. But that's not all;
Blake's decision to take on Bruce's mantle
— paired with the repairing of both the
Bat-signal and the Bat's autopilot
— keeps the legend of Batman alive,
even after Bruce Wayne "dies." Ultimately,
Batman lives on, and that was always the point.